- Ohhh, my gosh!
I got—uh, that's, that's all three.
I can't—can I start all three?
[Laughing]
Hi, Antonio Cromartie, and this is "Start, Bench, Cut."
I will be given a category,
where I have to start—start one, bench one, cut one.
I will start "Friday Night Lights." That's high school football.
That's just somethin' that's very big in the state of Texas.
I love it, and you gotta put Boobie Miles in the game, baby.
My bench will be "Remember the Titans."
I think there's a history behind "Remember the Titans."
I just, I just love how—one, the atmosphere, the storyline behind it.
"Rudy," I would cut. I didn't really get into—
you know, it was just somethin' that was not my type of feel of a movie, but,
you know—but that's just me.
Oooh, start. My starter, tequila.
Gotta have my tequila, you know?
From, from my Clase Azul, my Don Julio 1942, whatever it may be.
Gotta start with that. That's my favorite.
Vodka, I would have to bench vodka.
Simple fact, I'm not really a vodka person anymore,
but, you know, I'll go to that before I go to—
that'd be my second choice.
Definitely cut the whiskey. Not a whiskey drinker.
More of a bourbon. So, there it is.
Ohhh, my gosh!
Telepathy, super strength, super speed.
I got—uh, that's, that's all three.
I can't—can I start all three?
[Laughing] I would start super speed
just for the simple fact with super speed, I can get through everything quicker.
I ain't gotta worry about traffic. I ain't gotta worry about none of that.
Telepathy, I would bench, just for the simple fact—just,
I don't really need it.
[Laughing]
And I would cut super strength.
I don't, I don't—if I got speed, I got telepathy, I don't have to deal with strength.
OK, start with the wings.
Always gotta have wings. Gotta make sure you have your favorite dip with your wings,
your ranch sauce.
Ranch always with my, always with my wings.
Pizza, I would bench. Cuz pizza, you always have.
I think that's somethin' that you always are gonna have when you havin' a Super Bowl party.
Seven-layer dip, I'm gonna cut.
I'm not eatin' no seven-layer dip.
Just give me some queso and some chips, and I'm good to go.
[Laughing]
For me, start, it's gonna be "Carter III."
That's just somethin'—I'm a big Lil Wayne fan. I'm from the South.
So that's just always been me.
For the bench, it's gonna be "The Blueprint."
That's just—that's a classic.
You gotta have that on the bench just in case your starter don't work.
Cut "Get Rich or Die Tryin'."
It's a great—it's good, but I didn't really get into it as much because
that was just my feel at that point in time.
I'm startin' all three.
[Laughing]
And the reason I'm startin' all three is because they all are great at what they do
in every single sport.
But not only that, you know.
Comin' from a black background and who I am,
all three of them are—play at the highest level and have been considered all-time greats
at every single one of their, at every single one of their sports. And you can't take
that away from them, so all three have to be a starter for me. No bench. No cut.
All three of y'all are my starter.
I'm Antonio Cromartie. This was "Start, Bench, Cut."